Thank You Marsha very kind introduction
and I want to thank you for inviting me
to come and i was it's really a great
honor to be here and to be able to speak
to this sort of really high quality
audience and also many thanks to bonnie
rose shulman as well for the invitation
so I'm as I said very pleased and
honored to be to be here I am a
historian as if as you know so hold on
to your hats this is really a lecture
about history just by a little bit by
way of a warning but i would say what
you know better setting could there be
perhaps for an exploration of gendered
violence than the seventeenth and
eighteenth century world of
mediterranean piracy a world of
swashbuckling Corsairs of all stripes
whose violent practice of their
masculinity at sea rendered the water as
a place of danger threatening above all
the virtue if not the lives of helpless
females who could be captured enslaved
and then subjected to unspeakable
degradation and we have a wealth of
narratives that have capitalized over
the course of the centuries on this
particular version of gendered violence
from the earliest of the captivity
accounts in the 16th century right up to
a Victorian pornography which featured
you know volumes like the lustful Turk
plotline piracy and you can imagine the
rest right up to contemporary potboilers
that take white slavery in Arab harems
as their plot line so here's a recent
publication this is the fourth queen by
Debbie Taylor it is about actually a
english or scottish woman who married
the Sultan of Morocco is a Sultan of
Morocco and more about this more about
this later
I don't think it's a great literary
masterpiece but has a good cover and
then perhaps this storyline touches a
chord a gendered violence in its most
straightforward form posits the mail as
the aggressor who subjects his female
victim to violence as a means to assert
his domination and enforce her
submission inscribing on her body the
gendered relations of power that inform
and reinforce a patriarchal system and
the mere threat or potential of this for
this violence is often sufficient in and
of itself men cultivated form of
masculinity that suggests through dress
through accessories mannerisms that they
are active they are strong they are
powerful witness for example the
exaggerated and outlandish appearance of
many pirates how they dress how they
display their battle wounds peg legs I
patches etc even if sometimes we have a
Popish version of the same so the
vulnerability to violence is likewise
enacted by women who seek male
protection from male violence through
forms of femininity that may actually
shrink their physical presence be overly
thin on muscular alternately reveal or
conceal their bodies wearing articles of
clothing that impede their movement so
gendered violence takes its place in the
context when we usually talk about
gendered violence it takes its place in
this context of gendered power relations
as a critical tool used to underscore
and maintain male dominance but there
are complications and I want to address
three of them in the course of this talk
first most violence presently and
historically is perpetrated by men
against other
most victims of Mediterranean piracy
were in fact male it is other men not
women who are most likely to experience
male violence so was violence doing some
other work here in the context of male
social relationships that was the first
question second women are not
necessarily passive victims we all know
this we've all heard this so far this
morning and there are women who are
perpetrators of violence there are women
who use their femininity to confront to
deflect or perhaps to repair male
violence and what were these techniques
in the case I'm talking about and how
did they work and third gendered
violence can intersect with other
categories of difference when violence
is directed against someone of another
nation race or religion as well as sex
is gender simply another aspect of this
violence or does it serve to establish
some kind of overarching framework in
other words what was the connection
between pirate violence and the newly
emerging order of European Empire in the
Mediterranean with all its religious and
increasingly racial overtones so in
looking at these questions in the
context of Mediterranean piracy I want
to emphasize change over time as a good
historian I'm not dealing with gendered
violence as a trans historical
biologically determined aspect of the
human condition but rather as a social
practice responsive to transformation on
many levels the aggressive expansion of
trade activities for example or the rise
of the regulatory nation state or the
emergence of new forms of domesticity
they all shape the prevalence in the
forms of violence in the historical
moment the history of Mediterranean
piracy allows us to address questions
about the meaning and complications of
gendered violence in a dynamic period of
transition
a period when new actors and new forms
of economic political and social
interaction were crowding into the
Mediterranean world so the Mediterranean
just a bit of background there's a
history from ancient times of piracy in
the Mediterranean locals operating from
their own Shores intruders entering the
sea attacking or raiding coastal
communities as well as ships pirates
came in roughly two varieties we can use
the term to refer to what we might call
pirates proper that is people who are
operating on their own account who might
be professional Rovers or perhaps even
fishermen from coastal communities who
have fallen on hard times and take to
attacking ships in their vicinity but we
have another category of pirate and I'm
going to use the term for both these
categories by the way we have another
category of pirate those that we
designate pirates but who are officially
sponsored privateers or course sayers
typical of the early modern period i'm
talking about these are seafarers who
hold commissions and licenses in the
forms of letters of marque or reprisal
and either from theirs from a sovereign
state or sometimes they might enjoy the
direct patronage of their rulers and we
should understand that in the early
modern period these are not terribly
distinct categories the distinction
between the private pirate and the
Corsair primarily because one in the
same individual could slide back and
forth between these two particular roles
now for the Mediterranean I would just
note in passing that geography played a
role in the encouragement of piracy of
both kinds much of the Mediterranean
coast as I'm sure you're aware is very
jagged many small Bay
days Cove suitable for secure and
private Anchorage for pirate ships and
for their prizes it there it is often
there a lot of mountains and Hills also
around the coast which afforded caves
for the stashing of captured goods and
ravines that allowed for quick retreats
to the interior when necessary so pilots
could be pretty hard to find and even
harder to capture in addition it's been
noted that certain patterns of winds and
currents for example those near the
Straits of Gibraltar abetted pirates by
becoming ships and making it difficult
for them to flee attacks the technology
behind this is that a lot of pirate
activity was carried out by galleys some
of the well talked about some of those
slaves in military galleys but some of
those no doubt were sometimes put two
poetical activities as well and galleys
because their Road are much more
maneuverable and much faster than a than
a ship unless it's under full sail so so
while we've had piracy in this region
since time immemorial it was really in
the late 16th and 17th early seventeenth
centuries that there was a distinct
upsurge in pirate activity in the
Mediterranean and absurd in the sense of
the incidence of attacks on ships or
coastal communities and the violent
seizure seizure of the ships of the
cargoes of the people increased and this
increase is directly linked to the rise
of merchant empires and to the
corresponding overall growth in sea
trade on the one hand and conflict over
trade routes on the other piracy and
particularly course airing grew in the
Mediterranean as a result of political
and economic choices on the part of
emerging Dutch French and English
merchant empires whether they opted for
the imposition of monopoly or for free
access expansion of these empires
entailed the use of force at sea against
particularly against those whose roots
they wish to capture or
who resisted their presence it's been
pointed out that war and commerce went
together for 16th century Europe and
northern European merchant ships
routinely used violence against Spanish
Venetian or Ottoman ships that they
encountered that contested their
ambitions appeared to stand in the way
of desired access to certain ports or
simply proved irresistible targets fair
nombre del had has earlier taken a very
similar position in viewing the
aggressive appearance of Northern
European pirates in the Mediterranean as
a sign of bids by the English French and
Dutch merchant empires to establish
themselves by using a variety of tactics
including poetical activity so piracy
persists as a handy weapon for securing
trade advantage up to the time when
these new merchant empires the Northern
European merchant empires developed
effective national navies powerful
enough to protect their merchants and at
that point which I will get to a little
bit later in the late 18th early 19th
centuries European empires came to
forbid and criminalize pirate activity
including course airing and the official
fleets were given a monopoly over the
use of violence at sea so piracy in the
Mediterranean is also linked to and I
quote here pal Fodor linked to and I
quote the attempt of impoverished
societies excluded from the mainstream
of development to compensate themselves
at least in part for the losses caused
by the commercial ascendancy of the
northerners so these so-called
impoverished societies came to include
Italian city-states such as Venice and
Genoa these are the people who are
beginning to join the losing side in the
Mediterranean Venice and Genoa Spain and
certainly parts of the Ottoman Empire
particularly its North African provinces
and also Morocco
in the case of North Africa the Ottoman
provinces later termed regency's of
Algiers Tunis and Tripoli putatively
under the suzerainty of the Ottomans
gradually came to rely heavily on the
proceeds from course airing which
constituted a significant proportion of
state revenues from the late sixteenth
and well into the 18th century in the
form of booty of captives as well as
financial payments being made by
European powers in return for protection
for their ships from pirate attacks so
is it there was a bit of a protection
racket in place as well although the
targets and tactics might shift
depending on the state of war and peace
as well as changes in trade patterns
piracy in the form of course airing did
indeed emerge as a central survival
strategy for the North African states
whose legitimate trade had suffered from
European competition so just to
summarize here at the pinnacle of pirate
activity in the 17th century we find a
number of groups and low sigh of pirates
in the Mediterranean they have somewhat
different modes of operation but I won't
get into the details here but the most
important of these groups for our
purposes today at least were three the
first was Christian military orders
operating from the Italian ports of Pisa
and livorno and from the island of Malta
yeah doesn't I think maybe the next map
it shows up better yeah modern map but
you can see the island of Malta there as
well as the other most of the major
pirate ports at least make it on this
map so they're the Christian military
orders pisa livorno and above all from
the island of Malta there are the
state-sponsored Corsairs operating out
of the North African ports of Algiers
Tunis Tripoli and the Moroccan port of
cell a around in the Atlantic and then
we also have the newcomers in the sea
the Dutch English and French of course
the French are not entirely new to the
Mediterranean but they do see great
greatly expanded maritime activity in
this period Dutch English and French all
supplement their commercial activities
with piracy and they practice it in an
aggressive in armed form of mercantilism
so this is not by these by any means an
exhaustive list these are the main
actors but ships flying a variety of
flags including Spanish Portuguese
Italian Russian Swedish were all engaged
in Mediterranean piracy at some point in
the early modern period so piracy was
very much effective life in the
Mediterranean it was a widely accepted
mode of warfare and profit making it was
often state-sponsored and it was
generally viewed as business as usual
and we tend to think of piracy as
something disruptive as injurious to the
smooth functioning of political economic
social life and it's certainly true that
piracy had some very great costs in
terms of human lives material goods the
many anxieties it provoked I mean you
don't have to go very far to in your
reading to find that to realize that
people up from the early modern period
who lived around the shores of the
Mediterranean were had a very high level
of anxiety about what might happen if
they got on a boat and as a result of
pirate activity but piracy I think we
have to remember that piracy was also an
activity that forged political economic
and cultural ties at a time when they
were in rather short supply and served
as an important connector between rising
European empires the Ottoman Empire the
North African provinces it was really
central to the making of a distinctly
Mediterranean space and that's because
the whole business of piracy including
the marketing of purloined goods there
were a lot of black markets around in
these various ports the refitting of the
ships the ransoming of the captives all
these things whoa of webs of connection
around the shores of the Mediterranean
but of course at the same time piracy
was by definition a violent enterprise
and our investigation of gendered
violence therefore finds much to in
gage here so enough background I'm going
to get I'm going to get to the violence
here so let's begin by asking our first
question about the meaning of gendered
violence in the context of piracy as the
ships were boarded and crews and
passengers were overpowered captured and
subsequent subsequently enslaved what
kind of dominance was being asserted in
the process it was certainly in large
part male dominance over other men the
16th century of a 16th century account
where we have a lot of accounts
fortunately but there's one sixteenth
century account of a merchant ships
boarding by Ottoman Corsairs and this
account is by an Englishman by the name
of John Fox it might have looked you
know something like this I mean you can
you can see the setup here the you know
on the right you have the the pirate
ship and on the left you have a very
well armed by the way merchant ship
which they were I mean they were not
just peaceful sailing vessels these
merchant ships they they usually had
lots of lots of guns so as the ship's so
John Fox in his 16th century account
gives us a very stirring tale of the
actual pirate attack it is a stirring
tale of masculinity and militarism so he
tells us that the these what he calls
the Turks the Ottoman Corsairs start
attacking the ship and the English
captain raises his sword in defiance of
these Turks and then Fox says and I
quote so likewise stood up the owner the
Masters made boatswain purser and every
man well appointed now likewise sounded
up the drums trumpets and flutes which
would have encouraged any man had he
never so little heart or courage in him
not sure where all these drums trumpets
and flutes came from but
but any is telling the English crew then
fights valiantly some dying in action
but they are eventually overpowered by
the Ottomans who managed to wrest their
weapons from them and the survivors are
captured taken to Alexandria and made
galley slaves Fox's account of his
experience then grows a little sparse
until we get to the story of the great
and violent escape that he and others
make from Alexandria after what he terms
a hot skirmish with their captors so the
resistance to the boarding and the later
escaped have their male heroes John Fox
is among them and they use their courage
and strength to triumph over their male
enemies so the pirate encounter is
narrated with plenty of violence on both
sides the merchant ship is well armed
ready to resist the Corsairs are
practiced in their attacks and both will
fight like men until they lose the means
to do so once a ship was captured the
crew and passengers could be the most
valuable prizes taken by the Corsairs
available evidence does not allow us to
estimate precisely how many people were
captured by pirates operating in the
Mediterranean but the numbers were
significant just a few benchmarks in the
Year 1611 an Arab traveler was told that
the number of Muslim captives resident
in Malta at that one point in time
reached almost 6,000 in the later 17th
century we estimate that about 200 new
captives arrived in Malta each year but
this figure doesn't take into account
all of those who were captured by
Maltese pirates and then ransomed before
they actually reached the island and on
the other Shore Corsairs operating out
of the port of tripoli for example which
was one of the smaller of the north
african course airing ports had a modest
number of ships were still capturing
still had maybe 12 to 13 chips operate
they captured anywhere from up to 300
Corsairs in the 17th century three
hundred a year and of course a port like
Algiers had many more course airing
ships probably you know roughly fifty or
so in the 17th century and they were
English captives there were you know but
there were other captain really we know
the most has been written about English
captives I would put it that way but
there were many other kinds of captives
as well French Neapolitan Dutch German
Scandinavian Portuguese and probably
above all in terms of numbers Spanish in
as far as North Africa was concerned and
finally one in the spring of 1816 kind
of the towards the end of our story here
almost all captured slaves being held in
the North African region seas were freed
we're well past the high water mark of
captivity but still there were some 1600
of these slaves in Algiers almost a
thousand in Tunis and 600 and still in
Tripoli so as a valuable commodity these
captives were not as a general rule
killed or treated in a way that
threatened their survival that was
really not the point they were widely
perceived to be a valuable resource many
of them that many of the men were
skilled craftsmen actually with nautical
experience so they would have been
considered very useful people they also
derived their worth from the probability
of their eventual redemption and
ransoming was big business well placed
and connected individuals were usually
ransom speedily for high sums and here
is a ransoming seen these are Spanish
friars actually there were orders of
Spanish friars who specialized in I mean
that was their mission was the
redemption of captives and they would
make periodic they would make you know
periodic trips to North Africa to ransom
Ransome groups of captives this would be
for the poor captives not for the
well-placed who had their individual
ways of raising raising money but before
they were ransom they were enslaved and
violence or the threat of violence was
often part of the experience of
captivity a group of Englishmen held
captive in Tunis and Algiers in the mid
17th century petitioned the English
crown to help in raising the fifty
pounds per head demanded for their
ransom they sought a letters patent from
the king so that the money could then be
collected through various charities in
England and their petition is
instructive in its appeal to the
transgressions of their masculinity the
62 poor captives reported that they and
others are in a slavish condition and I
quote not only subject to torture and
most unnatural and abhorred abuse of our
bodies but by terror of future torments
threatened if our ransom come not within
a short time doth seek to reduce us to
the bitter perdition of our souls so
it's not only standard violence that
they endure according to this petition
but the most unnatural and abhorred
abuse that conjures up the image of male
rape whether we have an instance of
accurate reporting here or not and
there's no corroborating evidence to
suggest we do we can still conclude that
they fought an illusion to this form of
male violence violence that dishonours
men by treating them as women would be
effective in securing their release
Muslim captives as well reported being
physically abused Ahmed bin Mohammed bin
lkd the well-connected scribe of the
ruler of Morocco was captured by Maltese
in 1586 on a trip to Egypt and he wrote
in his memoir of hunger cold beatings
and tortures but as Nabil muttered notes
his account is exceptional in even the
brief space it devotes to the
description of physical violence
of the Muslim captivity narratives gloss
over violence and physical abuse a
subject apparently not deemed
appropriate for public discussion so
piracy entailed mail threats and
practices of violence against other men
violence that coded masculine traits of
courage strength and force the
centrality of violence to the assertion
of masculinity has been noted in other
relevant contexts at the time Robert
shoemaker for example found in his study
of the high number of homicides in 17th
century London that the mostly male
violence was often prompted by perceived
threats to male honor and the male need
to demonstrate courage strength and
independence by their willingness to
fight and i quote shoemaker for men
violence was a public method of
confirming their gender identity and
affirming their honor the subjection to
violence was by the same token and
emasculating experience but the ability
to inflict violence or at least resist
it was the mark of a man and so manhood
was being continually tested here the
drama of boarding the ship the endurance
of physical abuse the dramatic escapes
all these these things were trials of
masculinity and it was a masculinity
that was increasingly tied to forms of
identity as men represented certain
faiths or nations a point I will return
to but if pirate violence was mostly an
affair of men against men women were not
left out of the picture entirely as you
might imagine so we can now ask our
second question how did women
participate in this violence as a
betters as victims as buffers now women
could be found aboard ships of course
and in coastal communities and in both
places they would be subjected to pirate
raids and capture they were captured for
ransom much as men were but they did
have other possible destinations
including slavery in households in
konkani [ __ ] and
we'll talked about that this morning to
those destinations for female slaves and
certainly women feared piracy at sea and
were not spared the violence of capture
and enslavement okay this is a Eliza
Bradley an English woman who wrote a
very famous account of her captivity and
this is well a very interesting picture
of her being transported into captivity
you have to she's been captured at sea
the notion that most captured women were
passive victims who ended up in sexual
servitude however is belied by the
accounts of female captives themselves
one of the most intriguing of these is
the story of a Dutch woman Maria
terramax tellin who's narrative of
capture in the early 18th century came
to my attention through the work of
Khalid back away from the beginning
Maria did not appear to fit the victim
mode molt I'm sorry the victim mold she
was a crossdresser in her teens who
posed as a male to enlist in the
military regiment in Spain she
subsequently married a Dutch sea captain
and she sailed with him as captain's
wives often did in those days when their
ship was attacked attacked by Corsairs
from Morocco she bravely stood by her
husband as most of the crew fled she
then behaves with courage and cunning as
a captive of the Moroccan Sultan she
nurses her ailing husband until he dies
fends off enormous pressure from the
ladies of the Sultan's court to convert
to Islam eludes the Sultan's advances by
feigning to be pregnant and then she
chooses her next husband to kind of
picks him out the head of the Dutch
community the local Dutch community and
even prevails upon the Sultan to arrange
her marriage so she narrates one of the
dramatic encounters with the Sultan
whose wish it was that she convert and
stay with him so and she and I quote
here I hurried after him till the gate
through which the King was going to
leave
and prostate advice prostrated myself
again and said cut off my neck I prefer
this to becoming a Turk the King seeing
my determination and courage to be such
as of a lion and that I was hindering
him from leaving his palace cast
terrible looks at me but in the end as
we know the Sultana exceeded to all
Maria's wishes she then spends 12 years
in Morocco surviving with her growing
family through several changes of rain
through famines foo plagues and she also
grows in stature among the captive
community and takes on the role of
intercessory Nia thorities and her
community until she has ransomed along
with others by a Dutch organization so
Maria is the hero of her own story of
course and so we might expect to find a
little bit of embroidery here but the
fact that she presents herself as she
does intrepid smart worldly stalwart
says much about her will to refuse the
role of the victim she's also ready to
confront violence when necessary or two
deflect it if possible by the use of
various performances you know here's my
neck cut it off and also subterfuges oh
dear I'm pregnant therefore unfit for
the harem which was completely a total
lie actually so that the spirit of
defiance is mirrored in another account
this one by a Moroccan woman related to
Malaysia Suleiman the Sultan of Morocco
who was captured with her husband by
Maltese Pirates in the eighth late 18th
century saya delala patna been CD
mohamed bin Abdur Rahman wrote to the
Sultan to whom she is related to report
her own there there capture and their
conditions and no doubt to seek his help
with a ransom payment I'm sure the
situation is here the Pirates were very
well aware when they had a valuable
captive in in their hands and so they
would press they you know they would
single this person out and make special
requests for
very high ransoms for them so that's a
no doubt her situation and she in in
this letter she writes to the Sultan she
gives graphic testimony of her plight
and and I quote yes may God prolong your
life and increase your days all what has
befallen me I shall relate to you in
this missive today that Oh me who owns
me sits on a chair puts the inkwell in
my lap and smokes in my lap and the
smoke rises up my lap and against my
face I said to him enemy of God why do
you smoke in my lap and he said you are
mine I do with you whatever pleases me
so I think also interesting part of this
is the you know he's he's such AI mean
imagine using the inkwell as an ashtray
right that's a additional nice touch in
her presentation here so such attempts
to intimidate her however seemed to fall
short she refuses to recognize her owner
as her master and she continued in the
ongoing narrative she has she continues
to address him only as the enemy of God
and she disdains the barley bread she is
given to eat even when subjected to
escalating violence and excrement
covered broom is thrust into her face in
a blow to her stomach produces a
miscarriage she refuses submission the
confrontation and deflection of male
violence is further supplemented by
women's activities in the support of
their men folk then who fall victim to
piracy Maria stood by her captain
husband until his death and [ __ ] nuh is
negotiating not just her own ransom but
that of her husband as well other women
who were not captives themselves worked
hard on behalf of captured male
relatives for example the English king
charles the second cousin moreau earl of
inter qin the cousin and his son were
captured and imprisoned
and in Algiers in 1660 as well connected
noblemen they were considered high-value
captives and their ransom was set at
5,000 pounds ahead no I think 5,000
pounds actually for the two but it was a
king's ransom it was the Earl's wife
countess Elizabeth who swung into action
she first petitioned the King she's back
in England but she first petitioned the
King pleading that her husband and son
had for more than six months Ben and I
quote in miserable captivity under the
hands of those barbarous infidels and
thus have undergone the sad effects of
slavery and bondage and she requested
specifically that the king sent his Navy
to demand their release and failing that
and it would be failing that because he
wasn't going to do that failing that
that the King commissioned the English
console in Algiers to negotiate the
ransom then she became increasingly
concerned about the practicalities and
so in a second petition to the king she
reports that she has learned that the
English console in Algiers is not the
best of negotiators in that the ransom
business would be better placed in the
hands of an English merchant there a man
by the name of William writer and then
she also makes a very practical
suggestion about how the King might
raise the funds raised the money in
those days you know these were these
kingdoms didn't have a lot of disposable
funds at their that they could draw on
so she says um you know you could she
suggests that Charles raised the money
but from the London customs revenue that
would be a good source she says to get
you the necessary funds I'm sorry to
report her interventions were not
immediately successful the two years
later we learned that the Earl is still
in captivity and the ransom money has
been sent supposedly 5,000 pounds but
only 3,700 I'm sorry 03 he's still short
by 3,700 and they're good portion of it
had gone missing somewhere and so he
doesn't I'm not quite sure when he
eventually gets freed but it takes a
little while longer
so regardless of his fate its there's
little question that here that Elizabeth
had acted with assertion and focus in
her attempts to secure the Kings
intervention here Ottoman women might
also attempt to free relatives through
the medium of petitions to the ruler for
intervention on their behalf in one such
petition a woman from Algiers joined her
husband joined with her husband to plead
for help in liberating their son from
the Spanish pirates holding him from
ransom as you can see here after an
invocation after invocation she said
this is the petition of your slave is
the following this slaves son who is
also your slave was captured by Spanish
pirates and this is a slave in the
metaphorical sense right of slave of the
ruler was captured by Spanish pirates
from aboard an Algerian ship he was
taken to a spanish city called cart
duhaney the papers which came from Spain
are attached to our petition you know we
understand that one of the families
similar case asked you to send somebody
to the French ambassador to rescue their
son know that your slaves the parents of
this son are at the moment destitute and
cannot find a piece of bread to eat now
their condition is exacerbated by the
loss of their son so the petition is
that we beg you to look at the papers
which came from Spain concerning our son
and that you take our miserable
situation into consideration ie we
cannot afford anything and we beg you to
contact the French ambassador right so
you know I think one of the things
that's interesting about this petition
is it is signed by the mother and the
father right so both fatma and ismael
display considerable savvy about the
process necessary for the release of
their son requesting that the sultan
work through the French ambassador in
Istanbul to arrange the ransom for the
son who is being held in the spin of
Spanish port their request draws on a
deeply rooted ottoman and islamic
tradition of petitioning the sultan
directly in his capacity as the
protector of his people while at the
same time embracing the rather indirect
and convoluted means afforded by state
diplomacy it's kind of a nice work
through the French ambassador so the
prominent role of the mother draws our
attention here did her voice that of a
female and a mother carries special
moral weight and was therefore for held
to be effective certainly the role of
women as mitigators meanders of male
violence maybe being invoked here we
don't know the outcome unfortunately of
this particular petition but the fact
that this and other such petitions were
filed by parents together suggests a
belief that this is a good approach that
this approach might work and women could
also use the law to protect themselves
from some of the negative outcomes of
piracy in advance we have for example a
fatwa in which woman by the name of IG
been taught man been pliable and Saudi
who was the wife of a Corsair sailing
out of El mattia in Morocco she
basically goes to court in advance of
the sailing to have her husband agreed
to put her Affairs in her hands with a
legal maneuver which would allow her to
effect a divorce should his absence be
prolonged and course airing was a
dangerous activity and she was obviously
seeking to reduce the risk of finding
herself without a husband and without a
divorce and in which case she would have
had to under Maliki law wait for four
years before she could obtain a divorce
and remarry so well there's little
question that women could be victims of
male violence of violence calculated to
enforce submission in ways that are
anything but subtle when it comes to the
world of piracy in captivity at least
there's also a range of resistance
defiant subversion and mitigation on
display here women were not by any means
passive recipients of the violent acts
inherent and piracy so our final
complication concerns the intersection
of gender with other categories of
difference when it comes to pirate
violence to a great extent fair game in
piracy was defined by difference differ
of religion difference of nationality in
the early modern period it also took on
the cast of a religious war Walter
Manolo describes the early modern
European global imaginary or emergence
of understandings of the pattern and
destiny of the world as a whole as a
drama of the spread and ultimate triumph
of Christianity European captives were
want to give themselves starring roles
in this drama it was over their bodies
and their souls that the conflict was
raging our friend John Fox for example
narrated his escape as a Christian
triumph over Islam as proof that our God
was more powerful than their God
virtually all European captivity
narratives share this trope there is the
inevitability of the pressure physical
or otherwise to convert to Islam which
is mightily although not always
successfully resisted captives who did
embrace the new faith took particular
pains to stress the extreme duress they
had faced no doubt as a method for
defending themselves against the
criticisms or even inquisitions they
faced upon their return to Christendom
if in fact they had converted on the
North African site as well course airing
was cast as a Muslim Christian
confrontation l want a reese's
collection of North African and
Andalusia legal opinions although
assembled at the turn of the 16th
century was widely circulated in
referenced throughout the early modern
period we're discussing here these legal
opinions assume that pirates or thieves
of the sea as they call them that prey
on Muslim ships are all Christians
they're all Rome or nest Ronnie the
pilot encounter is invariably one
between Christian aggressors and Muslim
victims the legal literature also pays
due attention to the presence of
Christian captives in Muslim lands at
least some of whom were presumably taken
by Corsairs and the status of these
captives has everything to do with their
religious identity all captives are
Christian and those who convert to Islam
their status problematic in the legal
opinions it is Muslim pneus and
Christian asst that defines the
legitimacy of capture and slave Minh and
ransom in keeping with the fact that the
North African Corsairs were being
celebrated at home as warriors for the
faith engaged in Seaborn jihad so
Mediterranean piracy did have this
element of both a Fanning and feeding
off flames of religious difference and
if religion played a key role in
patterning and regulating violence so
did nation piracy was increasingly being
regulated by legal norms and agreements
forged by States so ships cargoes
persons were legitimate targets largely
as a result of their national or state
associated identities a regime of
treaties and passports evolved to define
and adjudicate the conflicts arising
from pirate captures pirates had rules
to follow and they usually chose to
abide by them in order to cloak their
activities whenever possible in the
stuff of legality and various people
have noted the pension of pirates two
were here to adhere to legal norms
Lauren Benton has a very nice piece on
William Kidd the English Corsair who
eventually ends up hanged even though he
did in by his own sites play by the
rules and a Molly greens study of the
tribe tribunale a of Malta which was
responsible for reviewing the legality
of capture is made by the Knights of
Malta no I'm sorry that's uh that's I
thought I had some Knights of Malta I
don't think I do um her book about the
Knights of Malta is I think a very
interesting one depicts the nights as a
somewhat Restless but respectful
subjects of the courts Authority they're
faced with a ban on the capture of
Christian ships cargo persons but the
multis Corsairs often try to argue that
even though the Ottoman Greek captains
I mean that that the Ottoman Greek
captains yes they were Christians but
they were sailing Muslim ships and
transporting Muslim cargo so they should
be fair game by the mid 18th century was
the ship's passport that had become the
chief measure of the legality of pirate
operations and that was regulated by
treaty agreements usually bilateral
treaty agreements and pirates had
learned to parse these documents very
carefully just to give you an idea of
kind of the rule of law and in this
whole picture in 1749 for example the
day of Algiers had to apologize to the
King of England for a seizure of English
ships by one of his Corsairs under the
pretense the Corsair had boarded the
ships and studied the passports and
decided they were irregularities or
there was another incident very similar
the same year in fact in which there was
a British Kings packet Commission and
that was captured by Corsairs using the
argument the ship was not carrying a
pass and Kings packets were not listed
it's exempt in the current treaty
agreement which the English felt very
much was a loophole that the Corsairs
were exploiting so it was national
identity and various instruments that
defined it that alternately protected
and made one vulnerable to pirate
violence but these lines of religion and
nationality that I've just alluded to
were often crossed and clouded by the
phenomenon of the renegade and the the
Renegades the renegade ohs were those
Europeans who had thrown in their lot
with the North African Corsairs and
sailed as crew or even captains of North
African course airing vessels and their
numbers were actually very significant
so in the late 16th century of the 35
captain's of course airing ships
operating out of Algiers 22 of them can
be identified as renegades so well over
half of them are actually captained by
Europeans one of the most notorious was
the englishman john ward who became
commander of a corsair fleet manned by
both ottomans and in
at the turn of the 17th century he
enjoyed a very successful career as a
Corsair captain converted to Islam
eventually retired in Tunis as a wealthy
man his biography was dramatized during
his lifetime by the way by Robert De
born in the early modern English play a
Christian turned Turk the this fluidity
of social and national identity that we
see in the case of the Renegades was
being witnessed time and again in their
careers and aboard their ships in and
aboard the ships that they sailed course
airing vessels recruited crews
characterized by high levels of
cosmopolitanism in Algiers we have
evidence for the presence of Spanish
Albanian Greek Hungarian French Corsican
Italian English and Dutch individuals on
board pirate vessels as well as the
Turks and mariscos and Arabs that one
might expect to find there Malta looked
the same although all Christian but
quite diverse sailors of French Italian
Spanish Dutch German and Dalmatian
background participated in pirate
cruises out of Malta well into the 18th
century we still find we still can find
a board of British privateering vessel a
crew composed of Greeks Neapolitans
Venetians and genoese and there were
many for our purposes European women
renegades as well those who converted
and then married into Muslim households
in the 1630s in Algiers one source
estimates that there were some 1,200
European women married into local
households of different ranks most had
their start as captives and then had
chosen or perhaps been coerced in some
cases to convert and Mary there could be
a very dramatic rise in social status as
a result one of the wives of the
Algerian ruler was an English captive of
humble background in another English
girl the one we saw on the cover of that
book oh and at the beginning
another English girl was married to the
Moroccan Sultan in the late 17th century
she took the name belkis and became a
valuable court contact for redemption
activities on the part of Europeans the
Renegades although a product of piracy
in one way or another really undermined
the categories of religion and nation
that justified in legitimized pirate
activity so how did the violence
informed and allowed by difference in
religion and nation intersect with
gendered violence as the story of
Mediterranean piracy moves towards its
finale we see a convergence of these
ways to signal in us in assert power
piracy continued to be a feature of the
Mediterranean up into the 19th century
but it diminished greatly in importance
as European conflict and competition for
trade in the region decreased and
British and French cooperated in
suppressing piracy the national
interests of the European empires came
to be better served by securing the
trade routes and the Seas they now
dominated and relying on their new naval
powers not Corsairs to police this
territory by the late 18th century
piracy was a fading activity pursued
primarily by the southern shores regions
that retained only a small and a
continuously contracting piece of the
Mediterranean trade routes and the
markets that had been their lifeblood
for centuries so piracy was rendered it
was not entirely eliminated but it was
rendered a rogue operation largely shorn
of its former coherence and its
transmitted Iranian networks as the
Mediterranean became a European sea
piracy was recast as a savage practice
an emblem of the barbaric which
periodically provided the pretext for
imperial adventures including that of
the French occupation of Algeria and
without widespread Mediterranean piracy
and the connections it forged through
these interlocking worlds of captives
and renegades and all the business
people who handled the ransoms and the
goods the lines of religion and nation
and gender could be drawn more strictly
and in ways that amplified the effect
so here is where we get a refitting of
gendered violence as a badge of
backwardness and depravity that was very
much part of a new attack of this new
attack on piracy the earlier European
renderings of North African Corsairs and
this of course is carradine known by the
Europeans Barbarossa and here we have a
portrait of a Corsair think it's called
Corsair with a bow by pier francesco
mola these are I would say respectful
pictures images of dignified masculinity
by the 19th century however this kind of
thing disappears in it is more the more
familiar image as that of the the North
African slave market with the image of
the white female slave that haunts the
artistic imagination of Europe and this
orientalist rendition of jacome and you
know among other things we see
introduced here which are totally absent
in the early period is the strong racial
theme so it's the exercise of a depraved
gendered power by the other who is by
virtue of uncivilized religion and
nation and now race as well but sets the
tone for the new Mediterranean order
that will be one of European control
gendered violence has now been placed in
the service of colonial rhetoric so in
closing I hope that Mediterranean piracy
or a little visit with Mediterranean
piracy has helped to focus our attention
on the complexities of gendered violence
past and present the Pirates violence
served not only to assert male dominance
over women but certainly to affirm
masculinity in conflicts with other men
women entered into this violence in a
variety of ways certainly as victims but
they might also collude with men in
violent acts as well as seek to deflect
or mitigate the effects of the violence
and finally we see gendered violence
taking new and arguably more virulent
forms as it intersects with evolving
categories
difference with religion with nation and
with the race okay thank you questions
just asked it when you state your
question that mr. Tucker will repeat it
because she's being filmed so just to
speak clearly and we have some time for
questions okay Phoebe I was really
interested in the captives whether the
violence that's represented as a
consequence of piracy being captured
that that sort of violence dippers is
always talked about different ways than
say
had someone been captured through a
caravan rate not lads like I'm just
curious about how violence was seen
differently in the sea vs on lath and
whether we have you know captive
narratives on land that might like that
contrast and maybe pick up on some I
haven't actually I haven't and so I
haven't read the captured on land
narrative so except in other people's
work there a couple of interesting
recent well Leslie Pierce actually is
working on women captives land captives
now so she's got this project going I
should probably compare notes with her
about you know whether or not there
seems to be some kind of significant
difference I mean the the problem with
the legal literature because I work a
lot with the legal literature the
problem of the legal literature is for
them a captive is a captive so they
don't actually i'll tell you how that
whether the person got captured on land
or sea it's not a distinction that they
find meaningful i don't know if that is
significant how significant that is but
that is one of the problems no yes I
question but I have I'm not sure it
it's relate directly wasn't talking
about you mr. Jerome man see that he has
problem and understanding
on the culture of the atoms or the area
if this oh yes she definitely does haha
yeah you're not right right right cover
because they don't want anybody I see
them you know that the Wonder Woman
right so that's it's about all that the
problem that understanding you know the
relationship between the destiny as a
female and
the owner right because in Islam also
it's acceptable in old like to marry and
to have as a media plan yes I mean that
this is a painting that is completely
fanciful it really belongs to the
Orientalist genre of painting so it's a
it's a fantasy you know it's it's a it's
a fantasy and an anxiety and an other
ring and it's doing a lot of different
kinds of work here right but it's not
it's not a depiction of any kind of
reality where no one would never claim
that what carry it you're no problem
from the other side it was like you know
why you know in the area of the Middle
East or around you know they are not
fighting for the rights of women or
women rights because the images you know
that appear and the Western culture so
this affect negatively you know
oh right right and it goes back to this
period i think you know i mean what's
interesting to me is that if you go back
a little farther in time as i'm trying
to argue I mean I'm not trying to argue
for some kind of idyllic past when
everybody got along and understood each
other and tolerated each other but the
sort of level of you know the violence
of the image really is a product of
evolving 19th century Imperial mentality
yeah yeah we'll funds towards France me
autumn subjects today for every wiser in
case of subject and treatment even law
ok so the question is about ransoming
and how widespread was or how active the
Empire was in the ransom II of its
captives I don't know the answer the
question that I would love to know the
answer to the question but I did find a
STIs petitions that's in the Ottoman
archives and there there a you know a
number of them I can't remember how many
I found but I found a number which
suggests to me that people thought that
the the Empire would respond now I know
we have a couple of famous cases in
which the you know at the level of
interfacing with other states the Empire
could be active particularly if it
thought that the other state had the
actions had contravened treaty
agreements so you do see there's one
famous case in which the Ottomans
actually send a delegation to the Dutch
to complain about an ottoman ship it's
been captured in the cargo was
confiscated and sold and they want the
cart you know they want the to be
compensated and they actually send a
physical delegation all the way to the
Hague to present their case to complain
to the Dutch and it's actually a cute
story gets the Dutch you know the the
Dutch whatever Council or whatever that
rules how long did the time they
basically are sending sending missives
to their
no their representative and Istanbul
saying try to get them not to come you
know it's going to be too expensive to
entertain them you know huh we'll try to
work this out so so they definitely did
intervene sometimes I think if it was a
costly enough and if I don't know
someone pulled the right strings
probably they could get the you know
intervention from the top and then I can
only assume because these petitions
exist that people thought they might
they might be able to get them to act
right yeah yes yeah I was wondering
about some of the fictional
representations of captivity
robinson crusoe moon that Cervantes
after
and if you deal with those at all as a
way of kind of like cheese again how you
know how it works in terms of working
trade right servantes very interesting
captain's narrative it's a muscle woman
who frees him and then he unveils her
Christian mm-hmm mmhmm yeah and of
course he was a captive himself so it's
got a strong autobiographical dimension
I would imagine yeah um yeah I don't
know yeah yeah but Sarah this is a
question about fictional narratives and
the number of fictional narratives of
captivity and whether I deal with them I
don't all right um yeah but but I think
it would be you know it'd be a nice
extension of the project to look at
fictional narratives as well
he doesn't talk about there's no mention
of women through the entire days have
just chat really fast right but it's
interesting because he protests his cap
he's captured my terms and if he's taken
to Algeria Algiers and he spends its
time that he says you know they didn't
treat me badly but you know anyone
ruby is just desperate for their liberty
city fridays then his ship rap is when
he's transferring slaves from Africa to
this hmm right right right yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I think that the fictional
you know these narratives could
obviously in to introduce and flush out
a number of questions you know so it's a
good it's a good idea yeah yes I mean
they are both 507 in my creative women
really come out on top every time yeah
yeah so you must have been discussed
even before
right right right right which would be a
very you know again it would be a very
good use of a fiction and other artistic
productions to to watch this what I
would think we will see it's what you
suggest is this change over time this
from you know towards more and more of
this kind of gendered violence as you
know the depravity of the other that
that is going to be introduced at a
particular point in time I'm guessing
and developed right but it would be a
good way to trace it I think yes
the discussions happening right now but
you and you spoke about you know how
violence is being conducted men against
men
we affirming like the kind of the order
of men's relation
but I was underneath he found any
accounts i guess of women and their
relationships with each other and there
you know
in violence earth
in working together in terms of
countering acts against men as from land
yeah I mean nothing comes to mind off
the top of my head although I know it
was the question of whether I need to
repeat the question so the question was
whether there had been in these
narratives evidence of women working
with other women to fend off violence or
you know the turret or mitigate it or
whatever nothing comes to mind off the
top of my head a lot of the women
narratives they have a lot of men in
them I would say all right and a lot of
them when it comes to violence issues
it's a lot of dealing with male violence
either you know shoulder to shoulder or
you know defending themselves or
deflecting it but but I doesn't mean
it's not there so I should probably go
back and and look and think about
whether or not there are instances of
women cooperating with other women in
their maneuvers yeah yes please
wondering about the faith when
been captured and have found their ways
found their way into marriages in North
Africa I was just wondering through what
mechanism without
do they command a grade enough price
really worth sort of selling them on a
local slave market rather than
and I was just wondering about that also
the dynamics of race in that sort of
relationship in the marital relationship
because we don't from the work of
toledano and others who worked on
slavery in in the Ottoman world that
that's white sort of European background
women often commanded greater crisis
world more highly sought after as wives
then
certainly more sought after than darker
skin blue
so forth so just wondering if you could
come
mm-hmm so the question has to do with I
just need to repeat the question but it
was a long question so but it has to do
with women who marry and become parts
part of Muslim households and how how
they get there right I mean what is what
is the path they take from capture to
living happily ever after whatever is
going on so we don't know much about it
as far as I've been able to see I mean
what is anecdotally okay and so what you
see or what is said or what is reported
it's probably the typical path would be
the following so a woman would be
captured and then she would be you know
brought into a household but usually
although the men were tended to be held
at least in North Africa in the in the
poet often in the public bond us that
they established to hold the men the
women were much more likely not always
but were more likely to be actually
farmed out to individual households so
once in the household of course not
everybody gets ransomed and not only
everybody gets ransom quickly I mean we
have if beegley if you're a poor person
we have stories of people staying there
for decades sometimes before the ransom
money comes through if it ever does
that's a minority of people but there
are people like that so someone could
end up by staying in a household for an
extended period of time and at some
point in that period of time at least
the standard story seems to be the woman
converts to Islam you know we don't know
what you know willingly Vaughn kors hard
to tell but the woman converts and then
some time after conversion doesn't
automatically free her but once she is
converted the tendency is to free her so
she converts she is freed and then she
marries right and she marries you know
into households at a of a variety of
different backgrounds you know as you
can see from the top she
married to the rulers household down to
a much more modest household so I think
that's the that seems to be the the most
common pattern for women who end up
permanently living in these households
you know um yeah yes 17th century yeah
um off the top of my head I don't know
of any for the rest of North Africa you
know what when you when you get a figure
like that it also it's a figure that
someone has estimated some observer has
estimated how reliable a figure is that
it's hard to say I believe this figure
this was from this Catholic father who
was there at the time and was
ministering to people in the in the
captive community and that was his
estimate I think we just have these
estimates pretty randomly when someone
makes one the stories of that then goes
on to but I also it's a long time ago
but it also used in the oral histories
that that's has spawned right
cent of that there's a this I mentioned
this there's a new volume by this North
African historian Khalid Becca we and
it's a it's a collection of accounts and
most of them actually our European
accounts of kept captivity women's
european women's accounts of captivity
but he has a really fascinating little
appendix in which he's found a few
things from the North African side and
one of them for example is a popular
song you know that he said has come down
through the ages you know and but which
definitely refers to that that period
another is a popular piece of poetry you
know actually you'd be really interested
in that yeah which also talks about kind
of glorifies course airing in fact from
kind of a more positive point of view
right I believe so yeah yeah i mean he's
that he is his career is there yeah
right yes now just to talk and I I
actually wanted to ask something about
sir framing masculinity in history
because you know from a gender studies
perspective in the region there's so
much more work that's been done on sir
in general and I really like the fact
that you're bringing back into this
discussion of the fact that this is
about men masculinity Palma sociology
and sort of masculine violence against
other men just bringing men as men in a
way back into the history of the region
and I because I'm not an historian I
would love to hear your thoughts on sir
how frequently is this being done a kind
of masculinity is perspective if you
will in Middle East history because you
know we're trying to do this now in the
sort of contemporary period in fact
ingenues be published a special issue on
Middle Eastern masculinity I'm working
my own work on it and I'm so just you
know gender in terms of masculinity
studies I would love to hear what you
think about it as an historian where
things are headed but then secondly in
terms of framing ok mr. contemporary
masculinity studies there's been one
dominant trope which is hegemonic
masculinity you know the men are in
these relationships in this dualism the
hegemonic dominant males and the
subordinated marginalized you and you
can see how it might work into a sort of
piracy narrative the ones who capture
the water I read verse as though you
know the captives is over but I actually
observe tired of that duel is a men's
room type of right against that that we
need to think of different ways of
talking about masculinity but I'm you
know in terms of framing and frameworks
that are useful if there are any could
you just talk a little bit about
masculinity in history from our area
studies perspective I would love to hear
what you think about it because this
seems to be such a historian part about
masculine
you know women across fit in but um you
know how how come I just kind of war are
people thinking of frameworks to
describe you know how men act as men in
history and okay so the question is
about masculinity in the Middle East and
in the field of history and if people
are are engaging with this issue and if
so how are they doing it it's this going
to be very impressionist ecause I
haven't looked systematically at I mean
it's on the it's on the radar now that's
a big that's a big step right so I think
historians Middle East historians are
interested in issues of masculinity and
they are beginning to address them I
mean I think of a recent book by Wilson
Jacob working out Egypt is an example of
this yeah right right very much and so
you can see that that's clearly a
subject that people appreciate it and
thought was you know worthy of
publication and attention so uh trying
to think of other examples I'm having
trouble even entered into this territory
answer contemporary graphic right to the
science studies i'm just really is a
lacuna i think in the contemporary
period and i was wondering it writes
your personals oh so yeah i'm thinking
of another gud john willis also has i
don't know if it's published yet but
also so there are a few people who are
working on masculinity I think it's
often in the colonial context that's my
impression I I would say that that's
where it seems to be people seem to be
focusing on and maybe that does feed
into the that dualistic sort of approach
that you're talking about and that may
be a bit of a problem actually so I
don't I wouldn't say it the best of my
knowledge we don't have a an original or
framework for it you know or even a
standard framework for it there just
isn't enough work out there to say what
the standard framework
might be right yeah just called Islamic
masculinities which is trying to lead on
that as men but you know it's not mostly
historical and it just seems like it's a
subject that sort of crying out for
attention removing like gender scholars
but I guess then the question is well
who's going to do the work I mean our
field as you can see you know I mean
there's so many women who work in gender
studies and doesn't mean that if women
have to you know work only on women's
issues I mean obviously not but I just
think its masculine studies you know
very important interesting and it has it
really been your sort of confirming my
impression which is here's what that
much work or carry I mean not to the
best of my knowledge no there isn't that
much work although you know I I had the
experience of trying to thinking about
this this talk instead of bumping into
it it was like how do you talk about
gendered violence in piracy without
taking men into account to right and the
fact that again men and and then I ran
it there are there is some interesting
with it's been done in European history
about male violence in the past and the
one piece of work I referred to by this
Robert shoemaker very and very
fascinating because what he does is he I
get to known in English history is that
there was this big fall off in public
male violence so you know you on the
streets of London in the early 17th
century and you were man oh boy watch
out you know was a dangerous place
because the one if you got insulted you
had to respond you know with violently
you had to respond with violence or
agreeing to by agreeing to a duel or
something just if someone says it's kind
of like that Shakespeare think someone
says you know you know your your your
nose is off center or something and then
you have it then you have to defend your
honor so in point of fact anyways he
showed that homicides were off the map
and they were almost all male on male
public violence and then what happens
over time by the time we get into the
18th century you know along into the
18th century this male and male public
violence falls off
violence becomes not good news in a
sense of violence becomes more male on
female and more domestic space you know
so what does that tell you you know it's
so but I think those these are the kinds
of questions we have to ask you know
what how does violets change in the
context of changing social mores of you
know new forms of domesticity of you
know new kinds of state intervention and
violence I think there are a lot of
different questions one might ask to
kind of historian such a strong pointer
that much of the violence historically
is male on male violence there's a sort
of assumption I think that we have this
men doing something violent to women but
in fact it's military it's types of
outlaw masculinity and violence you know
that men are killing each other and you
know doing my other things to each other
right to know I mean men are often the
victims of violence even today
regionally it's men often who are the
ones who are getting furniture too you
know yeah we never get murdered men you
know are often the ones in that position
right all right you know it's I've been
reading about violence I mean I've been
reading some of the more contemporary
disciplines you know the psychologists
and so forth who deal with this but you
know they sit i looked at one very
interesting large study they had done
about talking with people about violence
this is individual public violence kind
of and the kind the kinds of fears and
anxieties that people expressed we're
totally out of kilter with the realities
of violence on the ground so it women
were much more afraid of violence even
though in this urban community men were
much much more likely to be the victims
of violence so women were much more
afraid of strange men whereas they were
much more likely to be victims of men
they knew I mean the oil things like
that it was just our often our
perceptions are totally out of kilter
with the actual structure of violence
that we are ourselves embedded in
yes the intersection of the sort of
economy of piracy in the Mediterranean
and political power on the other and you
basically located a potential space for
this within the marriage between sort of
elites on the North African coast and
women who had been who were you know
potential for ransom but wind up
marrying you mentioned that they were a
diplomatic channel mm-hmm future
basically keep that B's i'm wondering it
is translated into for plenty more
political dialogue between you know
diplomatic channels in one country and
the Sultan on the other and whether it
can even contribute to an upsurge in
piracy because there is this channel you
can actually filter people through a
system more quickly if you have a
trusted negotiator writer on the ground
right there's sort of a perverse
incentive system there right so this is
a question about women captured women
who end up being married into elites in
North Africa and whether their very
presence kind of oils the machinery of
piracy and ransoming and so forth I
guess my first response would be I'm not
sure the machinery needed much oiling
you know it seemed to be functioning
pretty well they're ransoming was a big
business there were a lot of
intermediaries involved particularly for
example Ottoman Christians played a big
role in the ransom business European
consoles were very much involved to you
know in those in the 17th century
European consoles are generally not paid
salaries and so therefore they make
their money by various their traders and
they also do things for fees and this
was one of the things they did was they
you know were ransomed negotiators so
there were a lot of systems in place so
so I'm not sure how important this would
have been as though as a way of really
keeping the whole ransoming business
going i think it was going just fine you
know I I don't think it was a you know I
don't think it was a problem I mean
having said that you find people
referring to the fact that these women
that sometimes like this Bell Keys the
fact that she's there the fact that she
has the e
the Sultan that this is a good thing for
us and were able to get our business
done you know she's able to intercede
with us and just expedite our ransoming
activities and so forth so I wouldn't
discount it all together I just don't
know quite how much weight one would
give it given that as I said ransoming
was seemed to be going quite smoothly
yeah yes
where is Lady Mary goes to visit one
one of the elite Ottoman women and she
tells about being captured mmm-hmm and
then her family puts up a ransom and the
guy who's captured her he's in love with
them know pretty well do whatever you
want I'll give you back you don't want
to exchange anyway she says no I don't
want to give it back because then I'm
gonna have to hear the kind of you know
what I think she you know she wasn't
there was sexual there was a sexual
relationship between them though she
didn't want to begin back so she stays
with him when she says tells Lady Mary
how happy she was and that she so she
wanted to stay and convert go back
Europe don't find any like historical
record of that of that yeah um I haven't
come across that story this is about a
story that Lady Mary Wortley Montagu
tells in her letters of meeting a woman
in the Ottoman Sultans hareem who was a
captive and had voluntarily stayed right
had had basically rejected her ransom
money from her family and so forth and I
mean I think what we do know is that
people who go who are captives for a
period and then go back you know they
faced certain challenges upon their
return one of them being if if they have
converted or if it's thought they have
converted to Islam that's a big issue
particularly in the Spanish case where
they have this very active Inquisition
still in operation in the period so that
was not pleasant for people and could
end badly so that was
yeah yeah I think this would be better
yes yes i right she's fine with it yeah
yes years ago yeah we all know women
right right the Wilders the question was
the wildest shores of love what's the
historical you know foundation for it I
actually don't know yeah I said don't
know I mean but these are as I you know
these are you can think of cases like it
right yeah you can think of cases like
yeah they're yeah well that's a good
suggestion yeah it's also i just have it
through this in there's a harlot hem
series called the desert romance series
yeah all about women captives of very
arab and you'll capture them and they
end up falling in love usually with the
cat or you know right yeah oh it's been
yeah it's the hope the whole genre of
you know captive sex you know yeah
captive sex genre as i mentioned quickly
in the beginning I mean the whole I one
point was interested in Victorian
pornography and and this is a this is a
standard storyline that was one of their
favorite story lines they have to
actually that I could that I remember
off the top of my head one has to do
with servants right but but the other
has to do with you know with kind of
over sex servant women servants who are
get involved with these men but the
other has to do with you know virginal
English females who go on sea voyages
and end up being captured by pirates and
being in harems and then that all takes
up like three pages and then and then
the story really begins right all right
but but this was underground pornography
it was not publicly distributed but it
was underground pornography and that was
the big advantage of being a graduate
student at Harvard was they had in
widener library what they called the X
cage which had all the pornography in it
I don't know if by now by today it's
moved into the regular collection but
they had a fantastic collection of
Victorian pornography in the in the X
cage and the stacks right
this up but we thank you so very much
thank you